what's going to be the reaction of of
the people when he does get indicted
when he does get arrested he was
indicted he was arrested when he does
get convicted convicted and and put in
jail uh but there's probably going to be
even more indictments there's probably
going to be even more charges with the
way that things are going uh but but
when he's in jail how how will the
American people respond that's the
question I think they're listening to
people like us and they're wondering
waiting for us to tell them what to do
that's like the scary part kind of in a
way is like the not the responsibility
but also like things are hanging by a
thread right now and people need
guidance I know what they need to do
they need to buy cbw coffee the greatest
cup of coffee on also work out
yeah cuz Tucker was talking about that
the other day sort of he was saying like
you know I've because of all of these
indictments and everything like I I
become a bigger Trump supporter is what
he's saying I think a lot of Americans
feel that way and I think that would be
a breaking point for a lot of people and
I don't you know it's hard to say what
they would do per se but I think that
that would certainly be crossing the
line for a lot of people